you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at another game between alpha zero
playing on the white end and stockfish
so we have another French defense two of
the ten games are with this opening
alpha zero playing white in both cases
in fact same variation Steinitz with
move 405 and we have this same position
again in the other French defense game
black captured on d4 at the first
available moment not here
96 instead some attention on deform and
after Bishop d3 we have C form okay more
common are the moves b5 some grabbing
some Queen side space or Queen to b6
exerting more pressure on white center
but c4 in the game follows with a punch
the bishop drops back but notice now
that white does not have to tend to the
d4 square as much there's no longer as
much pressure on it and because he is
still present the d4 pawn he takes away
a very important square from two of
blacks minor pieces black continues to
press with b5 looking for B for white
puts a halt to that with a3 this can
only be this move B for can only be
prevented for so long but it's certainly
worthwhile to invest the move a three
for two reasons one white is saying with
the move a3
if you are to play b4 you will have to
first help my rook I will capture my
rook will be activated and two in order
for you to play before you will now have
to invest to Tempe before you are in
position to play it namely rook b8 and
a5 continuing rook b8 castles castles
right around this stage
questioned would it have been better for
black to prevent White's next move ef5
hey this is the move that was played in
the game f5 with this advance many many
white pieces are brought to life the
bishop the rook you can't capture
because you would lose an important
center pawn
have been prevented could it have been
prevented I like to take one step back
instead of castles can black play g6 in
other words clamping down on this
advance the answer to that is no because
g4 is in f5 gets pushed through still
and white is for choice
you can't stop f5 with g6 in the game it
was castles f5 black gets on with the B
for advanced or B for prep F take CEF
take C
instructional moment in the game I must
have cycled through this one at least a
dozen times and this was an instructive
moment for me
the top choice by stockfish is to play a
four and another top choice is Queen to
e1 here
alpha zero doesn't play either those
moves instead it's Bishop to d1 in fact
with the line Queen to e1 stockfish was
prepared to meet b4 with a capture and
then dropping the knight back to d1 but
the knight from d1 what is his future f2
no what is he doing from F to e3 while
that's on one of the key sixteen squares
on the board what is his future from e3
he would be negated by the pawn on e6
the idea here with Bishop d1 is to play
after b4 chop chop 92 this is the move
in the game what is his future it's to
go into F form okay from f4 you can be
sure his presence is felt he's putting
pressure on the weakest Square in blacks
can be six that's the base point of
blacks pawn chain and this is the point
that will require the defense of one of
the black pieces
see three follows in the game move 17
this is a pawn sacrifice by the way this
c3 advanced white is working still with
this space advantage since moved for and
black is giving white a pawn now in
order to mobilize the King night okay
he's gonna now have the C 4 square to
work with okay if c4 excuse me c3 is not
played right now the King Knight his
mobility at minimum the King knight's
mobility is diminished some other pieces
may be influenced as well but it's
certainly the king night who will
struggle to find some active role in the
position so for example if Knight b6 is
played in this position Queen e1 in how
do you activate the knight c3 cannot be
met with B 3 and B 3 can be met with C 3
in both cases at minimum the night on b6
is really a you know he's not doing
anything therefore black goes forward
with this pawn sacrifice c3 will ensure
that the knight gets some active play
soon it's going to be the best piece for
black B take C Knight b6 so how to parry
the knight move into c4 well Queen to e1
9 c4 and the bishop drops back to c1 is
this an inconvenience for white not
really
if it's true is now back on his home
square but he's perfectly satisfied
negating the night and doing some more
and he's seeing some other squares and
negating the night blacks best piece
B takes e follows Queen takes Queen b6
is throwing a punch this pawn is now
pinned so a Knight takes e5 is a threat
white gets out of the pin Knight B to
another instructive moment in the game
right around this point I questioned
good bishops bad bishops for white which
one is good which one is bad this is
White's bad Bishop this is White's good
Bishop on d1 we see this by the central
structure we can determine this
alpha zero gives up the good bishop in
this case right around this point I
thought well how do you stop the knight
from taking out the good bishop well we
just give up our bad bishop for the
night but we don't have that so I
questioned why well let's see Knight f4
is the move in the game and once this
move was played I understood the bad
bishop has a very important role to
support a Knight f4 move okay if the
bishop if the bad bishop in this case is
not around what will the night on e to
be doing well his future be so it has to
do keeping the bad bishop prone has to
do with ensuring that the knight is
activated
Knight takes the bishop on d1 the good
bishop is now gone Bishop d7 h4 slow
steady progress follows for white on the
kingside this is acting as not only a
flight square but white is looking for
more space with h5 and one idea for this
our one idea behind this is to maybe
control some light squares setting up in
h5 and g4 structure would combat this
potential idea for black to activate the
bad bishop
continuing rookie a
Bishop d2 connecting rooks I wondered
about one of these two squares which one
is better the bishop on d2 as we will
soon see will provide some nice support
to the base of whites pawn structure c3
d4 e5 so recon F to b8 white continues
to press on the King side one rook is
off Queens are now off and c3 so notice
the harmony in White's position
everything is defended except for the
rook King defends the poem pawn defends
the night everything is glued together
one way or the other and so where is
white vulnerable I don't see it white
still maintains a space advantage has an
extra pawn and because of this space
advantage this pawn on e5 normally a
space advantage is seen or felt in the
middle game but here too in the endgame
this space advantage is felt this is
allowing the White King to activate more
easily okay if we look at the e5 pawn
he's taking away the d6 square the King
the black king of course can never make
use of e6000 up the black King where
will he get activated okay his future
to determine you know what his career is
going to be in this endgame rook b3
we have a little back and forth with the
rooks on the a and B files for a little
bit
white wants to keep the rook on why
exactly well
this is another instructor moment in the
game after G for multiple offers of a
rook exchange white does not want that
what we're going to find is by keeping a
rook on board eventually white is going
to bring it to a point where white can
coordinate the rook with a knight and
with this coordination there is a a type
of synergy between these two pieces and
that ways into this endgame white will
be able to coordinate the rook really
well with the night whereas black will
not be able to coordinate the rook with
this dead piece on d7 let's see how we
get to that point
king of seven kingdoms e to Bishop c8
this Bishop is
a terrible piece his future so far has
been to go back and forth on these two
squares that's the bad bishop in the
French defense rip b6 Rock a6
King EA white is making progress with
the king for sure
King G to King g3 where is he headed
let's see Knight g6 follows rook a3 I
didn't point this out yet but the knight
if there's any idea for the night to
drop into c4 which is the weakest square
in White's camp still just like the King
Knight eventually made use of c4 if this
Knight tries to make use of c4 that
would give up the b8 square and this
rook would be able to cause some
problems to the King into the bishop so
it's important he stays around to
control b8 Rafi 6 Bishop d7 g5 pawn
takes pawn this Bishop on d2 at the
moment is overloaded he has to defend
the bishop has to defend c3 and you know
if you go forward with the capture here
with the knight first that would allow
Bishop takes Bishop and soon thereafter
the rook can grab on c3 so in the game
we have king g4 so now the pawn is hit
three times defended only once he's
going nowhere
this is instructive when you have a
situation like this where you could take
a pawn and you know he's attacked twice
defended once suppose you just add a
third attacker you know not capture it
right away that's what we have going on
here simply a third attacker is
attacking here maybe one day it's the
king who wants to be recapturing on the
g5 square and his destination can be to
scoop up the g7 pun as we're going to
see as this simplifies a little bit more
this endgame the g7 pawn is where white
wants to get to one way or the other
maybe with the King maybe with the rook
continuing bishop d8 rook b2
Knight takes g5 rook a2 is trying to get
into g1 the knight now drops back to f3
he didn't make this Mike didn't make
very many moves very early on there was
a knight to f3 move about 40 moves later
he picks up a pond and now he's going
right back to that f3 square to secure
the king post from rook g1 rook hates
ring and Bishop to e2 is clearing the
way for the rook Bishop a5 rook f2 so
now if black follows through with the
capture on c3 maintaining her restoring
let's say the material the cost is seen
by this rook getting brought to life
it's now coordinated well with the
knight on g6 black has to be very
careful so for example if black tries to
win the pawn back with Bishop takes c3
here what's going to happen is that the
knight gets out of the way there's going
to be a check another check this pawn is
picked up and you wouldn't believe how
fast that H pawn can run so black
doesn't go in for this rook a 1 instead
white gets out of the line of fire
Bishop d2 Bishop d8
gage - there's a threat here of h6
activating the rook and getting at the
king there's a lot of pieces that the
rook and the night can be influencing if
the rook is on the seventh rank the
night white is able to coordinate very
well with the white is able to
coordinate very well with the rook and
Knight in this endgame so anticipating
this we have ninety seven trying to get
rid of that Knight Bishop g5 dark square
Bishop Sargon black is still left with
this terrible Bishop rook b2 staying
very active this is blacks best piece so
it's challenged he's gone so what we
have here is a very good night versus a
terrible Bishop again his future has
only been to bounce back and forth c8 d7
all game Bishop d7 is the move
move 54 Bishop d7 if the rook takes the
pawn we're gonna have the rook sweeping
in this pond will be tracked down and
that ponds gonna bolt so as an example
chop rook f2 how you stopping the rook
invading King here Knight g6 check and
if King here well we're still going here
White is going to get at the pawn one
way or the other by way of g8 or f7 so
no rook takes pawn the bishop plays into
d7 to help defend against this rook
invasion preparing to play Bishop to EA
stopping a rook move to the 7th and also
even a night jump into g6 so white
inserts a check if the King moves the
rook is going to get out the pawn like
this so the bishop blocks he is much
worse off on the c8 square than d7 so
further away from controlling these
squares now
Knight G 2 white is giving up the c3
pawn in order to now established a
strong point a strong post on f4 rook
takes c3 Knight f4 so White has given
back the pawn but still has what still
has an active King superior minor piece
and space okay I would say that him in
this position both of the rooks are
active but white is going to coordinate
their ruck with the strong night whereas
black cannot do so with the Bishop rook
c1
rook a Inc King d7 so there may be the
temptation here to give a check and pick
up the pawn but that wouldn't work
because there's a skewer that would
follow the king and the rook would be on
this on the G file so King F 3 now this
is an idea
rooks III king of - King G - and if
black isn't careful there's this quick
idea to transfer the rook quickly to the
F file with check and then get into the
eighth or seventh rank so black gets off
of the open file rook to a-1 this is a
beautiful demonstration of rook
flexibility or of a rook threatening to
enter by way of f1 or maybe the seventh
or eighth rank how do you stop this the
rook is completely optimized from the a1
square 14 options from this corner post
rook c7
I'm assuming that's preparing to meet
rook f1 with rook f7 now the white king
is able to advance a little bit more
there isn't this fear like there was
previously of a black rook coming over
to g1 to challenge the Kings position so
he's stepping up supporting an eventual
Knight f1 move we do have this
okay seven kingi three getting off of
this diagonal so there is now an idea to
hunt down or put pressure on e6 and when
you do capture it you wouldn't be in a
pin now that the king is on g3 can also
view King g3 is a bit of a waiting move
rookie seven follows night d3 where is
he headed
he's very good from f4 where he exerts
pressure on e6 but he's even better from
c5 why well he's going to not only put
pressure on the base point but start to
take away squares from all three black
pieces
he is completely dominant from the c5
post so that's what we have the knight
circling into c5 and he is without
question the MVP of the game this Knight
completely dominating the bishop from
this point and black at this stage plays
g6 a sit and wait approach from this
stage instead of this advanced is no
good you know a sit and wait approach to
keep moving the King back and forth let
me just show why that is not a good idea
white isn't white would be able to
improve and eventually track down this
pawn and score a touchdown so what is
tried as G 6 H 6 is the reply and now
one by one the knight is able to simply
pick off all the black pawns and from
here there really isn't
or to note the night scoops them all up
and we're just a few moves away before
black throws in the towel move
95 and that's the ballgame right there
rook F seven black throws in the towel
stockfish resigns here so if the game
played out this is how it may play out
straight to check me
eventually promoting a pond
like has to give up the rook and that's
just one of many ways this game could
have finished so what more to add about
this game starfish playing c4 even
though it came with tempo confronted you
with an unsolvable dilemma have your
king Nights mobility diminish or your
chosen path
give me a pond in order to obtain some
peace mobility I obtained a space
advantage as early as well for giving me
a second advantage in the form of
material was the beginning of the end
you should know better than to release
the central tension every little alpha
knows
you